judging by andy no
there are about five protesters quote
unquote arrested and released in
portland per day
with varying serious charges will there
be a surge of convictions in the next
two to five years
what do you think will happen um
well as i unders i've admit that since
the fires have happened i haven't been
paying as much attention but um
i understood that the d.a had said maybe
maybe with help from other authorities
that he was not
going to be convicting any of the people
arrested associated with the protests
and the riots
in portland which is in a totally insane
position
but that is that is what i where i
understand us to be
somehow i i i'm speechless
yeah yeah i am prone to ranting go for
it
no i think it's probably best that i
don't but okay um
i i can't imagine you know we were just
talking about people
too dumb to reproduce and this strikes
me as the same level of dumb
where somehow you think civilization
continues even though you advertise
to the world at large that there are
certain rules they are allowed to break
as long as they do so under certain
banners
and those are some good rules they're
being allowed to break too like don't
set fire to people
and things that might have people in
them right those are really good rules
it's really essential that we just not
be flexible about those rules and yet
we're being flexible about those rules
um and anyway see earlier discussion of
why people who don't like donald trump
may end up voting for him because
this is just madness yep yeah to your
prediction from one or two live streams
ago the man's going to win in a
landslide
you know which is something we've been
talking about for a few weeks now
yeah privately but i just i
i don't see how any other outcome is
remotely possible at this point
i hope well i hope for unity
unity to unity yeah
you